all right guys
bang bang jack is back what's up dude
what's up man
how are you i'm good how are you i'm
pumped
you're killing it you're killing it for
those that don't know uh jack
is the founder ceo uh boss
uh brains whatever we wanna call it of
uh
of uh zapp which is the uh makers of
strike
uh we are uh proud investors of the uh
the business and uh jack and his team so
uh maybe for
two minutes just give us like the
overview for people who didn't listen to
the first time you came on the podcast
yeah so i'm jack um i'm a third
generation
finance here in chicago so my my
grandfather was chairman chicago board
of trade my dad
started one of the bigger futures
brokerages here and uh now
i'm in finance but in this weird
internet money asset thing
and i'm probably most well known for my
work on lightning in particular zap
and uh our flagship product strike is uh
really booming in popularity uh it's a
neobank of sorts in the fintech space
very similar to venmo or cash app but
it's built from the ground up to be
interoperable with
bitcoin and the lightning network
protocols which gives us a lot of
efficiencies and gains in the payment
space
uh explain that so when you say it's
built kind of bottoms up uh to be
interoperable
with uh bitcoin and lightning just
highlight that a little bit or elaborate
yeah so i mean i think there's a general
movement
uh in the fintech payment space towards
uh neo-banking this idea what cash app
is growing and booming in popularity
because
your money is made more accessible
legacy banking showing up to a chase jp
morgan with your passport
and documents proof of address is really
outdated
and people want accessibility with their
money they want their money
uh to to really act for them and be in
their pocket at all times and so we
wanted to replicate that model but use
bitcoin and lightning as it's a more
efficient money rail
um it's a value transfer protocol that's
inherently global it's inherently
cheaper it's peer-to-peer
um and it's an open public standard
that's collaborated on by thousands of
participants on the internet
and so we can do a lot of payment
whether it's remittance brick and mortar
online commerce rewards we can do that
all
likely much cheaper and much faster as
long as i can get your bank account or
your debit card to speak the lightning
and bitcoin protocol
and so that sounds really complicated
but that's why we do it that's where
we're an expert
and so we're really just building on top
of you know what paypal started what
square started and we think that this
is just the intuitive next step is
incorporating bitcoin
and lightning into that model and so
really what you're doing is you're
taking all that complexity and you're
offloading it from
the user having to do that for you to do
it right correct
yeah i mean these efficiencies have
existed in bitcoin the asset class
for a decade now at this point the
problem though
is it required a laundry list of you
know
you got to be a computer scientist
technical expertise you gotta
incur capital gains when you spend it
you got to deal with volatility
and it really priced out a mainstream
user or a mainstream business or whoever
to really act on this asset class and so
we abstract that away when you use
strike
you have no tax consequences you don't
deal with any volatility
it's as easy as downloading the app
entering your email and linking your
bank account to use
it can be used from anyone five years
old to 50 years old to 100 years old
and so we take all that on as a business
which is
the real innovation it's not only a
technical innovation but really there's
a lot of product and user experience
brought
um to us by us as a company and and i
think that that's
innovative considering this space you
know hasn't really prided itself on ux
over the last decade
and i think we bring serious value there
outside of the obvious technical
innovation
so let's maybe talk a little bit about
strike and the beauty of it being that
you know the user doesn't even know this
or they're using bitcoin they're just
sending dollars the recipient is
receiving dollars
talk a little bit just about how it
actually works and then
any metrics you want to share around
user acquisition or usage from those
users
just as you guys have kind of launched
in the early days yeah
um so one of the main innovations of
strike is abstracting bitcoin into the
background so bitcoin has a value
transfer protocol
um the value's been there ever since
satoshi wrote the white paper and ran
the first node
the accessibility though to that value
has been really tough
you have to be a computer scientist you
got to pay capital gains you got to deal
with volatility
and so we take that all on as a business
i mean that's our job to do that and as
a user you sign up you link your bank
account you scan a qr code you click pay
and it's really really dead simple um we
abstract all that we can get into the
live trading
and sort of the fanciness in the
background but uh the point
is that mainstream users can now benefit
from
what is the greatest value peer-to-peer
value transfer
that's inherently global that the human
race has ever encountered
and as far as our numbers i mean we
launched our
beta 45 days ago
we've already exceeded over half a
million dollars in volume we do hundreds
of thousands of dollars
every couple weeks at this point we're
likely to hit
our first million dollar month either
september or october
thousands and thousands of users we're
going to be entering
europe market uk likely in q3
which will open the gate to remittances
we've got a partnership with visa
some big merchants onboarding and the
acquiring side we
recently launched our rewards program so
we're flying at high speed i think we've
got some of the most talented engineers
in this space
and uh yeah good things are happening
man lightning works bitcoin works and
strike works so i think uh
the haters haters may be upset but we're
pretty happy with how things are going
every time i talk to you uh there's
always new products and uh
and more progress which is usually a
good sign uh
lots of people wanted to know about kyc
and then uh various states that you can
operate and can't operate in
so maybe just talk a little bit high
level just how you think about kyc
and state by state rollout uh and then
any updates there in terms of things you
guys are doing
yeah so um one of the challenges with
launching this product
is uh there's obviously compliance and
regulation involved
but to what depth is the question um the
only
you know severely regulated business so
far in this space has been brokerage
services and exchanges because that has
been the use case for bitcoin bitcoin
is a speculative
bitcoin do i keep going yeah of course
let's go
bitcoin is a a speculative
asset class that's been what's attracted
most users to date right is that
if i buy this thing i hold this thing i
get richer and that's not far from the
truth and so the most
successful businesses have been those
that offer that service
however we're very different we use
bitcoin almost as a utility function
so we're like a quasi processor and
regulators were really thrown off by us
i remember calling some of the biggest
law firms in the country and explaining
the idea and put their brain
immediately in a pretzel and
so it's been it's been a long haul and a
journey and they don't necessarily know
how to regulate us
so right now we kind of fall under the
exchange regulation with some exceptions
so long story short that's the reasoning
for the kyc do i think kyc should exist
for strike
no do i like kyc no do i think it's
helpful
no but do i want to go to jail and have
my business shut down
no and so i maintain relationships with
these people
at the end of the day they're human
beings they mean no harm and so
what we've deployed is a tiered kyc
so in the beginning when you download
strike you can enter your email and your
phone number
and 75 percent of the time that's going
to be enough and you're able to use this
service up until certain limits and then
as you
use the service and grow as a user will
need more and more and more information
these limits aren't hard-coded in fact
they aren't even a strict law again we
kind of just fall in this no man's land
we are
really innovating and uh the first of
its kind in this space we're almost
making the laws with regulators as we go
on
which is fun and painful at the same
token so
that's my as transparent as i can be
rant about kyc
if they were up to me it wouldn't exist
but i think it's even more valuable for
us as a business to comply and push
forward because we're really paving the
way for uh
many more in this space to follow in our
in our footsteps and uh making great
strides so
yeah do the best we can and you call
this
tiered kyc yeah so we break it into
two steps there's light kyc and what we
consider full kyc
uh light kyc gives us enough information
for our banking partners and regulators
to feel like
they know relatively you're a real human
being
you exist um you're not a terrorist and
that
you can make consumer level payments
because at the end of the day
um we're not allowing people to send 500
grand of cash overseas yet
these are small retail payments a retail
users mainstream type user
and so regulators and banking partners
feel comfortable where
i got your name i got your email i got
your phone number you know what
you seem like a good guy you're allowed
to scan a qr code on our watch
and that's okay but if you start
exceeding limits of you know a couple
thousand bucks five thousand ten
thousand dollars
well hey if you don't mind what's your
address because you are you are spending
a lot of money or
what's your birthday and so this is an
active conversation i mean i used to be
an engineer all day all night now i'm a
suit that just happens to prefer a
hoodie
but i spend all my time talking with
regulators really grinding them down
into what they're trying to accomplish
explaining lightning to them and
get hopefully get these limits removed
and get them comfortable with the idea
that
bitcoin as an infrastructure piece is
going to play a part in payments
and that doesn't mean that anyone's at
risk of laundering money
um or funding terrorists um it's it's
very similar to
you know what stripe does or what square
does and they don't require you
to give your social security number
um when you want to be a merchant on
their platform so i think we'll get
there
but to their credit it's all new and uh
rightfully scary
and and so that's kind of uh the
transparent inside look
at a day in life for me talk a little
bit about um you've done a fantastic job
going and meeting with these regulators
and
um really translating kind of the things
that i think people in the bitcoin
community
uh know and understand and are excited
about to uh i'll call it regulator
language right or kind of uh you know
adult language
if uh if they were saying it but
ultimately
i'm assuming that these people are uh
not excited about this like you said
kind of
brains in a pretzel uh but they seem to
be coming around and so talk a little
bit just about as these conversations
have progressed and you've gotten to
know these people
like like that uh transition for from
regulators and from law firms and things
like that into like oh well this really
cool idea like we want to actually help
make this happen rather than fight it
yeah
so i think an important point to keep in
mind is that at the end of the day these
are all human beings
and uh i don't think any of them are
acting maliciously more so than just
doing their job
um the real risk that bitcoin poses
to a local regulator so not the
president of the united states who
ultimately
has great control over the us dollar and
a strong relationship with the federal
reserve i'm talking about
local state regulation the risk it poses
to them is getting them fired and
getting them in trouble
and ruining their reputation and so what
they can't have happen
is give someone like strike a lot of
leeway
and have that backfire and have strike
end up you know funding the next
terrorist attack
and they're fired everyone's you know in
the can bitcoin's reputation is down the
chute
and so that's the real risk and so um
what's good for me
is just going hey shaking their hand
letting them know i'm a human being too
i mean no harm
i'm not trying to fund the dark web i'm
not trying to
allow people to transact privately on
malicious services
i'm trying to improve payments i think
payments are really expensive i think
that there's a lot of opportunity to
make things faster cheaper i think
remittances
should be a free and instant service and
that people shouldn't
have their lives put in harm's way in
third world countries by trying to pick
up a western union check
i think that i can solve that problem
and they really
understand that and as soon as i can
explain the technology give them a demo
have them download the app
um no one no human being wants to be an
enemy
i think part of being a human being is
uh
the opportunity to be part of something
bigger than yourself i think
everyone in the bitcoin community can
relate to that that's one of the
beautiful things about bitcoin is no one
is bigger than bitcoin and it's really
great to be
a part of this thing i think regulators
feel the same thing
they don't want to look at bitcoin as
maybe probably
the greatest investment opportunity and
technological innovation of our lifetime
and likely for centuries to come
um and they don't want to be in the
enemy and so
i think they're very willing they just
they need some
job security just like the rest of us so
that's that's my impression and uh
they're good people they pick up my
phone call um i'll get them cub tickets
when when they give me favors you know
the whole nine the whole nine
talk to talk about fees and how strike
makes money i saw a lot of people
tweeting saying you know
um kind of how the hell is this possible
and how do you make money
yeah well i you know how does square
make money right
how does no one charges the consumer
there's no native business model for the
consumer for you
to offer p2p payments or
even if your visa you know your debit
card
you're not charging the guy who's buying
the coffee he's already paying for the
good or service the very clear customer
is on the acquiring side and so there's
a few
revenue models that are super intuitive
to strike is that we're getting involved
in the acquiring side
and so right now acquires which is fancy
word for merchants
they foot the bill in all of commerce
right and so
we think we can offer them a similar
better service
for cheaper than what they're paying now
we also are
a otc desk of sorts is that we trade all
of our own flow
um so how does a trader make money i
think you guys can all answer that
question yourself and i'm a trader so
we also handle all of our own flow so
we're very similar to robinhood and
sense is that we
handle and live trade consumer retail
flow
and then you know there's all sorts of
sub industries and payment space like
remittances i think right now
our main priority is finding target
market
fit and ensuring that this product is
here to stay that it scales and we
understand the landscape and where we
can drive
most efficiency but as far as business
models go i mean
they're all over the place i think we're
we're
in a really really good space i i
totally get the caution
uh in that you know if you're not
paying anything then you you are the
product and that i'm selling data or
anything but it's very clear in our
terms
i mean i personally would never do that
but don't take my word for it it's in
our terms of service it's in our privacy
policy
and the consumer is not our customer
um the consumer is a valuable asset to
us as a company we we really value
the fact that you guys all prefer to
send payments over strike and that you
enjoy our service and we'll continue to
deliver to you for free
but that is as honest i can be with you
without giving away you know
the secrets that are worth millions of
dollars at this point so
don't give those away jack
um you had a uh at this point what was
called epic
and viral thread uh about ethereum
uh and vitalik et cetera uh i'll just
let you take it away it's your stage uh
talk explain what was the uh the thought
process there
and uh has your mind changed at all
yeah i mean i i wouldn't say my mind has
changed there's certainly things i want
to clarify um the point of the thread
was not to discourage
uh innovation and people trying new
things
i'm a big fan of people trying new
things and i'm one of those people
so i do respect vitalik uh to great
lengths
in certain categories my problem is
there's a few things i have issues with
one is that ethereum
is a is an attempt it's an experiment
with no technical backing as of
as of yet to date um there's no proof
that what they're trying to do
is going to work and so far it hasn't
really worked
however the marketing is the exact
opposite and that's my huge
problem is that it seems that their
marketing is malicious
it's misleading and it's intentional
and i wish that they would be more
transparent and more honest about that
because it's
in return very damaging to the
cryptocurrency space
when ushering in new users and these
users are getting burned
and getting an experience that is just
false advertising
is uh my first thing and my second thing
is uh
ethereum i think is very damaging to
bitcoin in that same sense
uh in that um they they
you know claim that the bitcoin
developer community is malicious and
mean
um they claim that bitcoin is slow that
bitcoin
isn't cheap uh and they really use
bitcoin to uh self-market themselves
and i think it's selfish and i think it
really i mean i myself have spent my
entire adult life and career in bitcoin
and uh i don't think that that it's fair
and i think
i know people like vitalik owe early
bitcoin developers an apology
and i think it's about time someone
called him out or
maybe i mean it's long overdue someone
called him out but i'll put it this way
i'm not
scared to call them out so that's that's
my you know
high-level two-minute summary is that
you know i appreciate ethereum as a
project do i think it's working
no do i think that they're lying in
their marketing and they're telling
retail investors as it's working because
they got a funnel in retail somehow
last time i was icos this time it's defy
yeah i think that is happening i think
that there are people
that are knowingly lying to retail
investors and you know
in the securities industry that's a
that's a crime
and i think that uh they have no problem
conveniently
uh blasting individuals in the bitcoin
space like greg maxwell and bitcoin the
project um to their own personal gain
and i take that personally because i've
dedicated my life to bitcoin i really
really don't appreciate that
so that was more or less my uh my
my qualms we'll do the uncensored
version next time
[Music]
but uh explain a little bit about the
misleading marketing i think that this
is a nuanced point here that
uh when people hear that they discuss i
don't really know what that means
so elaborate on that yeah okay so
in this cryptocurrency space trade-offs
are very well defined
technically so the reason bitcoin may
appear slow
it may appear expensive that's because
it's decided to be decentralized to be
censorship resistant so as far as i'm
concerned
there has been no technological
breakthrough to provide
censorship resistance and a
decentralized property
faster and cheaper okay and and this is
not up to debate this is just
math and so for example for some
blockchain
or cryptocurrency project to advertise
themselves
you know it in that realm like oh we're
faster and cheaper than bitcoin oh and
we're also decentralized
and we're also censorship resistant um
according to math
last time i read you know research
papers that is a lie
bold face lie um and so that's just a
high level example that i think everyone
can relate to you've seen the coin
market cap advertisements and such
and so uh or vitalik will say things
like i don't see any difference between
a light
client node and a full node i mean
that's just
a bold face lie or you are
you know dangerously idiotic on the
topic
either way not good news and so i guess
without ranting more that that's that's
what i mean is that
sure there can be blockchains that are
faster and cheaper but let's take
the decentralized and censorship
resistant labels off those do you mind
because
they can't accomplish them all and i
know that for a fact it's just computer
science and
you know it would take 10 more satoshi
white papers
to the level of brilliance that satoshi
delivered to deliver on all the promises
of ethereum and the other top 10
alt coins in the in the uh overall total
market cap and so
that that's my problem is the computer
science isn't there but but the
marketing's there
and it's really misleading to innocent
retail investors
so my favorite uh test to run with
people is
all this defy and uh and stuff like that
that comes to be decentralized
i just asked the founders uh if the
government came and said you had to go
to jail if you don't shut it off could
you shut it off
yeah right like oh oh you could okay
this is not decentralized
right like that's the whole point is if
there's like a kill switch
it's not actually decentralized it's not
censorship resistant it's not you know i
mean like all of these examples and
i think that we're now getting to the
point like there's a there's a very
real uh argument to be made that if
uh ethereum was found to be um
a security if ether was found to be a
security and was told to shut down could
they shut it
and i think they could probably yeah and
if
the government asked for the existing
supply would they be able to answer
probably not it's it's really scary
um i i like to call this whole altcoin
trend
i like to call it an arbitrage on the
trend and what i mean by that
is if altcoins in my opinion
they're taking the arbitrage difference
between the overall
interest that society has in
cryptocurrency because i think
at this point it's fairly intuitive that
it's a massive investment opportunity
and it's a technological breakthrough
that should not go unnoticed
fair enough however to the ability
that someone can understand why it's
important
how it works technically i mean there's
a large gap between there you're getting
everyone between high school kids and
you know 70 year old grandparents that
are opening coinbase
accounts and wanting to to put money in
this asset class um
do they know the difference between a
full node and a like client and what it
means to be sufficiently peer-to-peer
and decentralized
no so in within that arbitrage
opportunity i can create
wood coin and sell it to you and i think
you know
naturally markets get efficient and so
that arbitrage opportunity
is going to shrink and get lower and
lower and lower and it was much easier
to sell wood coin 10 years ago than it
is today
and it's going to be much harder to sell
wood coin 10 years from now than it is
today
but i like to call it an arbitrage on
the trend um
and is it a good thing or a bad thing it
kind of depends on your viewpoint of you
know
do you want a centralized party like a
regulated entity like the
scc or something saying what should and
shouldn't be allowed and what should and
isn't you know efficient sufficiently
decentralized
probably not so is this uh the best way
to go about making an efficient
marketplace
in this industry maybe but it's
dangerous
and it's dangerous and a lot of people
are going to lose a lot of money and
they're innocent
and so it sucks it sucks to see
give us an update on lightning network
you are
one of the world experts i would say or
those close to
what's going on there yeah well i think
you know the most exciting update is
it's working
it's working which uh wasn't always a
guarantee
as in even as long as a few years ago
um so it works right like we're
shoveling you know millions of dollars
like i said through it
and uh as far as some of the excitements
on the horizon
um we are lifting the limits the
lightning community is lifting the
limits within the protocol
so talk about being responsible with
your marketing and responsible with your
rollout
lightning had really severe limits so
you could
not open a channel bigger than 0.16
btc you cannot send a payment size over
0.042 btc and those limits now are
lifted because the protocol has proven
to be
secure enough and reliable enough and
still wouldn't pour all your money into
it we'll we'll
do that as zap as a business you know we
consider ourselves
enough expert but uh yeah i think that's
that's what's exciting
is that you're talking about a protocol
that
is instant settlement and self-clearing
on an asset class that's natively
digital
and inherently global so you can
transfer value anywhere in the world for
essentially free
and essentially instant that for the
first time in human history
and so that is an insane thing and now
you can do that without any real limits
and so anywhere between consumer retail
uh payment activity to large traders
having private relationships with
exchanges and doing live arbitrage with
you know hundred thousand dollar
lightning payments and millions of
dollar size channels
everywhere in between i mean it's really
i think it's a huge deal and i think
over the next six months or so that'll
that'll be the big narrative is uh
getting more and more capital on because
these limits are lifted
um literally quite literally betting on
you and lightning
to be successful so i agree with you
last question before i got a fun one for
you is
talk a little bit about where the
lightning network is going so you kind
of just hinted a little bit at kind of
the movement of millions of dollars and
you know large channel sizes et cetera
but just kind of continue going down
that thread if you will
yeah well i think um one of the bigger
opportunities
for lightning is uh fixing the
inefficiency that is
in uh the marketplace within bitcoin in
the exchange space and the liquidity
space
arbitrage opportunities settlement
between familiar counterparties
i mean it takes a long time and it's
generally expensive
just to settle between these exchanges
between i mean liquid network for
example the block stream
is working on i mean that's a solution
valued in
hundreds of millions of dollars right
the capital that's backing that and the
brains behind that
and lightning has a chance to achieve
that potentially even better
to give you some relative sense of the
size of this opportunity in dollar terms
um so i do think that right now
lightning seems to be too well feed
chickens
and draw dicks on a you know
digital art canvas um
okay but now strike is involved and now
remittance is on the horizon and now
we're doing cashback deals now we're
making it
much cheaper instead of 2.9 percent plus
30 cents for a merchant we can process
merchant payments for free
and then i think the next step is going
to be drw
cumberland jump trading the big market
makers in the space are all of a sudden
arbitraging over lightning channels
doing large otc
trades over lightning this market is
becoming extremely extremely extremely
efficient
fast-paced and uh cheap which is you
know
gonna it's gonna increase the velocity
of the asset
magnitudes and uh and that'll be
appealing to
a set of investors and a set of market
participants that maybe not don't have
the interest quite yet
um but i think it'll be a big deal and
uh mulling them over
it's going to be amazing this gets
adopted globally i really don't think
people understand the innovation here
nor do they understand
uh how small it is today and how big it
can get like the
um the delta between where we are and
where we're going is
absolutely massive in my opinion yeah
everything about this industry uh the r
r makes no sense in your favor not
not against you but in your favor i mean
uh the numbers are
you know once in a generation so you
know lucky lucky to be alive and
involved
and smart enough to uh to find jack
wallers building this
perfect so uh
last question for you a more fun one i
know you're a big big basketball fan
how did you survive the last couple of
months without going to play basketball
nor be able to watch
the nba on television i don't know man
every morning i check my pulse make sure
i'm still alive
um i don't know i mean you control what
you can control right
all these events in 2020 as a
you know blanket description that have
been unfortunate
uh you know bitcoin specifically is a
technology that
is built for the paranoid i think so all
of us
love speculating on the fact that the
world's crumbling and the world has
really delivered on that paranoia
and taking basketball away from me for
example
is one of the things i never would have
expected so how have i survived
um [ __ ] if i know but i'm still here and
i'm standing
uh so i really hope it doesn't do that
to me again and then next time i might i
might die
uh but yeah i'm excited the playoffs are
back on now i'm not a deli fan
uh because of block fi and uh i'm i'm a
spencer dinwoody fan nets fan
because of you and i just anyone win but
lebron
as long as lebron doesn't win this year
i don't care that's my only ask
so one of the most depressing things i
saw during uh the like really heavy
lockdown period was in new york they
went around
these guys literally went around to
every single playground and they took
the rims off the backboards
yep and i was like come on really whose
job was it that they showed up and like
all right you gotta go take all the rims
down across the city
and i was just like i guess that's
literally what they're gonna do
so they're pretty serious about it it's
been chaos man
it's been chaos like come on guys the
least you can do is
let us put up a few free throws with a
mask on but i guess
not all right man where can people go uh
download strike people hold on before
jack says this
go try it out it's super legit fast
as hell it's cheap you can send money
anywhere in the world
uh and you do it all over the bitcoin
network
uh and you don't even realize you're
doing it so go and download strike where
can they go
yeah well we're crushing it man we're
now if you just search strike in the app
store we're now the number one result
so you can just yeah how about that so
you can just go search strike in the app
store
uh for specific links you go to beta dot
strike dot me slash
download
or just go to the app store and search
strike correct
and yeah we're all over twitter um i'm
the most accessible human on the
internet
every handle is just my full name i'll
answer every dm
and uh yeah i mean i write this at the
end of all my blog posts this community
has been so great to me as an individual
and so great
uh to the work i've done and the company
that is zap so
i appreciate all your support the
feedback i read every customer support
ticket so uh
i really really appreciate it doing a
great job man we'll do it again soon
thank you
yes sir appreciate it buddy